thank you very much indeed um ladies and
gentlemen welcome to this Intelligence
Squared discussion on the war in Ukraine
one that despite the eye-catching
Troubles of the British government right
now could not be better timed nor could
it have a finer cast the title of the
discussion is the fabulously pompous
fulcrum of History the topic is the key
what are the lessons that history can
teach us about the Russian war in
Ukraine and to address that question we
have three wonderful guests we have
hopefully a wonderful audience uh some
great questions and perhaps most
importantly a decent amount of time to
chew over the questions and the answers
as they come there's always a slightly
ghastly moment now where I sing the
Praises of our panel as they have to sit
there and squirm but we will plunge
right in so max Hastings is a journalist
a broadcaster and author of more than 30
books former editor of the Daily
Telegraph former editor of the evening
standard contributor to nearly every
National newspaper there is and his
latest book which will be available in
the foyer
um is Abyss the Cuban Missile Crisis
1962. we may be hearing a little on that
topic as the evening goes on McMillan is
Professor of history at the University
of Toronto Emeritus professor of
international history at the University
of Oxford BBC wreath lecturer and her
most recent book is war how conflict
shaped us
Peter Frank pan is Professor of global
history at the University of Oxford his
most recent book is the new Silk Roads
the present and future of the world that
is our panel thank you I didn't squirm
at all
and very briefly on the format of this
evening the first 45 minutes will be
given over to me lobbying questions at
the panel uh after that there'll be
roughly the same amount of time about 40
minutes for you to love questions at the
panel there are standing mics you should
be able to see them standing microphone
there and there and then I can't quite
see it because I'm blinded by the lights
up in the gallery there as well
um so I'm the best thing to do I'm
afraid is to sort of go to the
microphone and wait to be called
um uh it's just otherwise we're having
tolerable delays as people make their
way to the mics we don't have roaming
mics for those of you watching at home
there is a box beneath the screen in
which you can see us all uh you can type
the questions in there and then I will
see them here and put those to the panel
as well and we hope to get through as
many questions as we possibly can I
would urge you to put questions rather
than statements to the panel it
generally produces a better reaction but
that all having been said I would like
to extend my thanks again to our panel
for coming here this evening my thanks
to you and let us begin the first
question
um I'll put it if I made to you Margaret
are we fighting the Third World War
no I don't think we are and I think it's
actually very unhelpful analogy I think
it leads to panic it leads to thinking
about this war in a way that we
shouldn't be thinking about it at the
moment what we're seeing is a state to
state war between Ukraine and Russia
it has of course the potential to turn
into something wider it already has
drawn in outside forces outside support
and so it certainly has the potential to
develop into something wider but this is
not a World War yet and I think we
should hope very much that it won't
become one the two World Wars we should
remember were absolutely devastating in
their impact the second world war even
more if that's possible in the first
world war because it involves such large
parts of Asia as well and the third
world war given the types of weapons we
have today really has the potential to
polish us all off and so I think I'm not
saying we shouldn't contemplate it but I
think to call this the third world war
is wrong because it's not that and let's
say a prayer that it won't be that yet
Max
I agree with Margaret um that it isn't
the Third World War I do think what
we're discovering from this uh horrible
regional conflict is we're being
reminded that we live in a Perpetual
nuclear age that uh for 30 years since
the end of the Cold War in 1991 we've
all behaved almost as if nuclear weapons
have been uninvented as if they weren't
there now what this crisis has reminded
us partly because President Putin has
made it his business to remind us is
that those nuclear weapons Putin still
has the largest nuclear Arsenal in the
world now I entirely agree with Margaret
this is not the third world war but on
the other hand the potential as long as
you're dealing with nuclear weapons for
something horrible to happen is still
there and when people talk sometimes
some of the very bellicose rhetoric one
hears about Russia
um I think reversing I just published a
book on the Cuban Missile Crisis unto me
the one lesson that the last from that
one is that President Kennedy in the
Missile Crisis displayed a mixture of
resolution and caution and what I think
the Americans have been doing very well
in this crisis is to display the same
mixture of absolute commitment to
Ukraine and the resolution but also I
don't think anybody in Washington
forgets the caution bit of the fact that
as long as we're dealing with nuclear
armed States you always have to be
incredibly careful to prevent this from
becoming something worse
Peter
well I suppose if if uh if Margaret's
wrong we're not going to live to see the
consequences so that's always a good
answer to have isn't it if this is the
beginning of the third world war
um and it escalates in a way that are
the worst case scenario is that really
is it
um I suppose as a historian the question
would be if we let's say the survivors
in a cave would say when did it begin uh
because it didn't begin on the 24th of
February 2022 uh you could plausibly
argue I think for for a good Mark that
2014 was when this started when Russia
invaded Ukraine and occupied it we did
nothing that's a separate story and we
can talk about that uh you could argue
it was maybe 2008 when Russia invaded
Georgia and again we didn't really do
what we should have done or you could
argue that it sort of really the seeds
were sown at the end of the Cold War as
the Berlin Wall came down the Soviet
Union dissolved and that's how the
Russians want to frame this right so
what Putin garbage who died a month ago
or so now uh were adamant that the seeds
of all the confrontations were sewn by
the way in which Russia was treated
after the war began after the wall came
down rather and so I think we have to be
very careful to first of all work out
what exactly we're looking at you know
is this a localized conflict where Putin
has tried to make a quick land grab is
this something much more profound much
more existential that is about the West
it's about conquests of large patches of
territory and where do we where do we
carve that up and I think we haven't
thought that through particularly well
partly because we're so busy with the
logistical problem of keeping the
Ukrainian Army supplied Margaret can I
can I ask you about this question of a
hybrid War because I suspect the answer
to the World War III question slightly
depends on on where you sit doesn't it
if you are in Russia and you see
economic sanctions from the West you see
military supplies from the West flooding
into Ukraine you see a constant to and
fro in the battle for opinion you might
think that the West is pretty heavily
involved in this war that it's not just
a regional conflict as it's been
described here
well there's a difference I think
between taking measures that are warlike
and actually fighting and the West at
the moment isn't fighting Russia
although it is certainly doing its best
to support those who are fighting Russia
so I don't think yet it is it is a third
world war and we don't know I mean what
we have to hope I think is that it
doesn't develop and as Peter said we
don't know when it started really and
with any War you can go back and you can
go back and go back and you could go
back to actually go back to 1917 when
the Bolshevik sees power in Russia and
sent Russia down a particular path
deeply suspicious of its neighbors but
wanting to reconstitute the tsarist
Empire but what I think we have to worry
about always is is the the possibility
of accident as well you know we we have
too many well we have too many
possibilities for something to go wrong
you know in Europe I think
if the first sector first world war
hadn't happened people would have said
oh it was just like the crisis in 1912
and 1913 and we didn't get a full of
all-out war and I think a lot of people
don't want an all-out War but the danger
always is when you get armed forces in
close contact with each other I mean
what if the Russians for their own
reasons drop a tactical and well nuclear
weapon I I agree with Lawrence Freeman I
don't think that's tactical if you use a
nuclear weapon a threshold has been
crossed but what if the Russians were to
drop something on Poland what what
happens then what how would the with
polls respond how would the West respond
and so I think we have to be at this
moment very very careful we're dealing
with a possibility and I think Max is
right we you know there's a lot of
bellicose talk
um Often by those who aren't actually
fighting it's always easier to say we
should fight for the last Ukrainian when
we're not actually fighting but I think
we are in a very dangerous situation and
we have this combination of very high
tech War I mean you mentioned nuclear
weapons it was also biological War
there's chemical War the Cyber War you
know we've already seen in the north of
Germany last week the whole train system
was out because someone hacked the
German the German system and all those
underwater cables which carry the fiber
optic cables which carry the
communications among Banks all the
things we depend on are so vulnerable
now we're realizing just what could
happen can I try one historical parallel
on YouTube that an awful lot of people
today are saying we should never have
allowed the Russians to get this far
um we should have had Ukraine in NATO we
should have intervened in 2014
I don't think the West should ever
approach itself for having tried
extraordinarily hard to embrace Russia
as a partner in the community of
civilized Nations and I do see a
parallel with 1938 that some in in my
view of sensationalists historians today
argue that
um the Western allies should have gone
to war against Hitler in 1938 at the
time of yearnings now I don't agree at
all partly because in those days an
awful lot of people all over the world
still were not convinced that Hitler had
to be fought still were not convinced
that it was necessary to have to
participate in another huge War by 1939
that had changed that the Western allies
were able to go into World War II
extraordinarily United because it was an
understanding that everything had been
tried
um to strike civilized deals with Hitler
and it had all failed it there was a man
with whom you couldn't do business and I
think something of the same is true
today that
um that there is a clear understanding
today as there was not that would not
have been in 2014 that Putin is an
extraordinarily dangerous and I'm very
reluctant to use the word but yes evil
false in the world and that he's got to
be resisted and fought and I believe
that there's a better chance of the West
being able to stand United against Putin
today than there would have been if we
got up against Putin earlier or if
they've been I think it's crazy to talk
of having had Ukraine and NATO because I
think it would have been so divisive a
year or two ago but I don't know what he
was Ukraine's application to join NATO
was turned down in 2010 so there was no
sort of there was a attempt to want to
join and one could perhaps understand
why I don't disagree with anything you
say Max the only thing I would say is is
that um in the 1994 Budapest memorandum
under which Ukraine gave up its nuclear
weapons
um uh United States Russia the Russian
Federation and the United Kingdom
guaranteed Ukraine's territorial
integrity and that is a problem in 2014
that under Obama and under the Cameron
Administration here in the United
Kingdom we fudged what was going on
about what those commitments actually
meant
Max can I pick you up on nuclear because
it comes round to the book you've just
published doesn't it give me some
questions we've seen a lot of chat over
the last what 10 days about that
situation what are the parallels are
there parallels well they're only the
good news today
um in what the world was terrified of in
1962 was going to be General war between
the west and the Soviet Union which
would obviously been a catastrophe of
the planet because it meant nuclear war
and one thing we have caused uh Jack
Kennedy has become very controversial
figure especially in the United States
today especially because of his
treatment of women
um well for this for purposes we're
talking about this crisis I don't think
we need to go go there what we can say
is Kennedy displayed in 1962.
um extraordinary wisdom in seeing from a
very early stage that at all costs
nuclear exchanges terrifying to read the
transcript so listen to the audio tapes
of the first day meeting in the white
house when they discuss what they're
going to do on the first mood the mood
of the American armed forces was we got
a bomb Cuba and invade Cuba and take on
the Russians and the American armed
forces Chief were ganging to do that and
um somebody said well what happens if we
do invade Cuba and uh
um The View was that probably the
Russians would take out West Berlin
which was then an enclave in in Europe
and Robert Kennedy said well then what
do we do and the chairman of the Joint
Chiefs of Staff at this meeting
um said said he said go to General War I
guess if it's in the interest of ours
um said Kennedy said nuclear exchange
and
General Maxwell Taylor said guess you
have to
and thank God John F Kennedy had the
sense to say yes yes I mean I'm worse
things I even had one worse things were
set but John F Kennedy said at that
first meeting
he said
um
we all have to understand that nuclear
exchange will be the final failure the
final failure he said everything we do
here has got to be directed towards
seeing that we don't get that now today
I don't think we're in anything like
without rehearsing the whole crisis I
think that one thing that is scary
is Jack Kennedy was able to see in 1962
scope for a bargain with Khrushchev in
particular what the way the deal was
finally struck that the Americans
formally undertook not to invade Cuba
um then or ever and privately and
secretly Kennedy promised Chris job he'd
remove American nuclear weapons up from
Turkey
now today it is much more difficult tens
of thousands of people have died as a
result of Kristoff's of of Putin's
aggression it is far more difficult to
see the basis of any sort of bargain
that either president zielinski or uh
President Biden can strike that won't be
rewarding Putin's aggressions so I think
it is I think this crisis is less
dangerous but on the other hand I think
it's more difficult to see the path out
of
Margaret can I get pick up on a point
that Max made there or that Max
illuminated and that's the role of human
beings in international relations
because so much of the discussion seems
to treat uh the actors as rational
actors
um are they no it
it's fantasy sorry thank you um as as
the rational economic being you know
that we all make rational economic
decisions based on full information and
think things through
um you know it's a convenient
thing to have if you're developing these
series but where I think a lot of the
realist political scientists the people
who say it's all about interest you can
just simply measure it and it's your
States always behave in a certain way
because of their interests whoever's in
charge it doesn't really matter I think
they leave out the individual they leave
out the role of emotion often and I
think we would not have had this War I
mean if this war doesn't show how you
need to bring in the role of individuals
if you have someone in office who has a
great deal of power what that person
wants what that person does is going to
make a difference you know a British
prime minister particularly at the
moment doesn't seem to have a great
great deal of power
and so perhaps it doesn't matter who's
in office but it does actually matter
who's in charge of China it does matter
who's in charge of Russia because they
have built or they've risen to the top
of a system in which those office
holders have a great deal of power and I
think we wouldn't have had a war in
Ukraine without Putin I think this is
Putin's war and I think the role of
emotion I think we're also realizing how
important it is I mean when people
looked at the relative size of this
Russian and Ukrainian forces I thought
well there's no way that Ukraine can
hold out for more than two days which is
what the Russians of course thought they
thought it was going to be a cake walk
down to Kiev and they apparently had a
puppet government in addition to their
dress uniforms they actually had an
actual live puppet government in that
long train that was coming down on Kiev
and we all I think and I was guilty of
it as well then the Russian certainly
did we left out the determination of the
ukrainians who were fighting an
existential War to survive
Peter Well it helped that the Russian
army was supremely incompetent yeah uh
badly LED they didn't understand basic
Logistics uh they hadn't realized and
they've done all these training
exercises they do with great Show often
with Partners from from other countries
um that their their tanks had much lower
mileages than they thought they did and
so you had this 70-mile Cube because you
couldn't get vehicles to the front so I
mean I think that's right I think with
with Putin the problem is is not
emotional acting it's being a bad actor
and Putin as all opportunists are and as
Hitler was and many other leads in
history uh is a is an opportunist and
you can see why he thought things would
play out in a different way he thought
we were weak Heath well it starts with
absolutely right it starts with Margaret
with all the intelligence reports from
Ukraine with it he'd be welcome with
open arms if intelligence of Russian and
FSB Intelligence Officers and Kiev had
chosen the apartments they'd move into
after the great uh Conquest he was
absolutely certain that Ukraine's
Ukraine had no fighting spirit let alone
competence but beyond that he looked at
Europe post pandemic economically
stressed he could see the chaos of
brexit which is almost incomprehensibly
crap how we've been as a country in
terms of the leadership regardless of
our political Persuasions or whether
you're pro-brexit I'm not here for that
but no one can argue that we have had
strong and stable leadership in the last
three or four years and on top of that
we've had all the kinds of disagreements
where we've we've detached from the rest
of the world to solve our own problems
that that's opportunity for a permanent
member of the Security Council is a
challenge you could see macron calling
NATO brain dead as quite a clear signal
you could see the incompetence of the
way that the United States ditched
Britain and its Partners to pull out of
Afghanistan and the way in which that
was done with U.S Marines smashing
keyboards to try and make them unusable
and taking parts off very expensive
pieces of Kit you can see Poland and
Hungary effectively by the being or
about to be sanctioned by the EU and
you'd probably take a view that you'd
fight you'd face vertical resistance
particularly if you can see what
happened in 2014. so Putin gambled on
all of that and through a series because
of as Margaret said an authoritarian
structure that is extremely slim there's
no institutional protection anywhere up
the whole way up you can see why he
threw the dice and thought he was
absolutely bound to win and like most
opportunist gamblers you you can win
often but if you get it wrong you get it
really really badly wrong I think one
thing we don't
um
one thing we don't hear enough about and
we don't say enough ourselves
we all are an extraordinary debt of
gratitude to the United States
that without the Americans nobody should
kid themselves Ukraine would by now be
toast if Ukraine was dependent upon
European assistance military and
economic and although we talk a lot
about this quantity of weapons we've
sent it nothing compared with the
Americans and I think our leader should
be saying to Washington should be
expressing extraordinary gratitude to
Washington and should be making the
Americans feel that we understand what
we owe them because another president in
the White House might have behaved
completely differently and um and oh yes
and we might we may in 2024 have another
president we've got to start in Europe
taking security seriously we cannot rely
on the Americans always bailing us out
and by gosh they have bailed us out this
time around no I agree with you and I
think
what if Donald Trump had been president
what what if he had actually won the
election yeah you know but he would have
been congratulating Putin his new best
friend and saying what a great Victory
um but just to go back to what Peter was
saying about Russian assumptions and and
Putin himself I mean there is a terrible
thing that you know it's the all
dictators should be warned about this
the longer you stay there the more
isolated you get the more you'll only
hear from people who are flattering you
to tell you what you want I'm sure a lot
of intelligent failures were people
telling him what he wanted to hear I
mean if you're an FSB agent if you said
to me if you sent a note a report back
to Moscow saying by the way a lot of
ukrainians actually probably will fight
for the country that would be the end of
your career and so I think Putin had
convinced himself there's also really
interesting element here he thought the
West Was decadent and have you noticed
how often he talks about gender and he
talks about same-sex marriage and he
talks about transgender you know there's
something really deeply weird there but
I think he he had convinced himself but
no I think this is the fact that he
fixes on it
um you know who knows I mean I'm not
going to get into Putin's psychology
because that would be like getting into
Hades but you know I think I think there
was that assumption and again it's it's
what people have in their minds when
they do something and I think he had
certain things this might was going to
be easy the West wouldn't do anything
and now that the West has responded and
now the Ukraine has responded so
effectively and shown such military
prowess he's stuck what does he do now
PT yeah I think I was going to say I
mean without falling falling down to the
circle of hell and what a glass of wine
on as we sit and talk to talk about that
one I think Putin psychology is partly
that we're all decadent but that's
framed and from his perspective so far
as we can tell from the idea that Russia
is the last Bastion of decency
civilization and so on and that has run
through since he took office or took
power at the end of the 90s it's been a
constant theme of Russia seeing itself
as the last place standing as The Third
Rome is a really important part of
Russian historiography and sort of
myth-making of you know Rome fell and
then it was the bat on was passed to
Constantinople in New Rome and Moscow is
the Third Rome the heir of the Orthodox
traditions and so on that there is a
kind of very powerful Motif in using
history in that way to try to to frame
what it is that Putin is trying to do
and you know for what it's worth and I
mean I hope we'd also talk a little bit
about deeper history or history further
back all my colleagues who worked on
medieval Kiev and Kevin Russ sort of
from the 9th 10th 11th century all lost
their jobs 10 years ago you know this
wasn't something that has just popped up
in the last year or two or even since
2014 the sensitivity around who the
ukrainians are where they fit within
Russia's idea of the outside world and
you know I mean it's a matter of
Interest I can't really see everybody's
hands but how many people and I'm not
going to Point At You know that Putin
wrote these crazy essays about history
right everybody how many people actually
read those essence
Margaret okay so you know Putin it's
sort of slightly unusual this long essay
about Dimitri biansk which is pretty
arcane knowledge or the the way in which
Polish nobles were awarded with land
Holdings I mean as a historian I can't
help be admire that people are
interested in history but maybe not not
Putin but what's most interesting I
think about that lecture was how he ends
he says Russian Ukraine have a very
complex history and I'm open to a
dialogue to resolve these and then he
says but the way this would be resolved
his last sentence if I quote it
um is I shall I can't read my own
writing without my glasses on what
Ukraine will be is up to its own
citizens to decide and what he meant by
that is that Ukraine has given a choice
would absolutely want to join Russia
right they would want to join the third
round they'd want to stand up against
homosexuality they want to stand up
because of the Nazi Instinct that they
want to align with the fascists in
Russia right that all that works quite
well so the Russian miscalculation is
not just about miscalculating the
Western response it's the Deep
miscalculation about about how the world
actually looks and I mean we're not here
to talk about China this evening but
that I think important configuration
about what is it that intellectual
politicians military leaders have been
fed for the last 30 years of how they
understand the Cold War and the Cuban
Missile Crisis how they understand the
post-cold war period and how they look
at things like oligarchs who've all
owned property here in Yachts all over
the Mediterranean how they how that's
seen and understood by not just
cryptocrats and oligarchs themselves but
by normal normal Russians and what was
once the Russian middle false it's not
just I'm a great fan of Orlando five
years and you've got a Russia story yeah
um which is not a history of Russia what
Orlando frag is for whom I think knows
as much about Russia as anybody in
Britain and he argues in this book it's
a short book and it's simply an account
of how Russians have portrayed their own
history and their own past over the
Centric and his essential thesis is that
Russians have been inventing and
Reinventing a narrative about themselves
which most the rest of us wouldn't
recognize for a moment since about the
17 18th century and above all because
Russia has no natural land or sea
Frontiers that successive Russian
leaders from Peter the Great through
Catherine the Great through Stalin and
so have been constantly seeking to
redefine the to demand the right to
decide where Russia's rightful Frontiers
lie and that's a right that most of us
in in this Hall tonight would agree we
cannot possibly concede but essentially
Orlando's point is that Putin is simply
the latest in the long line of Russian
leaders who demanded this right to say I
say this is where the frontiers of
Russia belong and this is terrifying
Margaret as a historian does it surprise
appall or Delight that Putin spends his
time using history
so badly doesn't he you know he takes it
I think very seriously he used to go
every summer he perhaps isn't doing it
now to conferences of history teachers
and tell them that they must teach young
Russians the correct patriotic history
and I did read the essay that he wrote
in 2020 and if I'd been grading it
because I'm a very kind person I would
have probably given it a d and said you
made a lot of effort here and you you
know you didn't write this many words
but quite frankly it's not very good
knowing what I know today I would fail
it
but it is he he has woven an historical
narrative and I think we didn't take it
seriously enough I heard Fiona Hill who
also knows a great deal of Russia who
was the for her pains was was the Russia
advisor in in the Trump White House and
she has some very interesting stories
about that as well which he said you
mustn't tell anyone of course we've all
been telling everyone but but what she
said about Putin was that he thinks in
his own historical framework and I think
you mentioned this Peter that he thinks
back and you did Max he goes back beyond
the 17th century he goes back into this
history which seems to him to prove and
in some ways it's very like the
Nationalist histories of the 19th and
20th centuries it assumes it was always
something called the Russian people that
exists through eternity and the
ukrainians were always part of the
spiritual Unity with Russia and we know
that's not how history works the Nations
come and go they Define themselves in
different ways and there was no Russia
when Kiev Kiev and Roos was set up there
was no Russia there was there was there
wasn't even a Muscovy and but he sees
this some this eternal progression
through history and I think it does
affect the way he sees the world and he
also has been very influenced by these
right-wing Russian theorists who argued
the Russians are much more spiritual
than the rest of the world that they are
this Eurasian power which unites Asia
and Europe that they are there's one
Theory I think I forget which one it is
um that we're all each race is created
by cosmic rays I mean I think Putin May
believe this and the Russian cosmic ray
came last and so the Russians are the
most vigorous and youngest that makes
perfect sense Peter well another thing
that Fiona Hill has talked about is that
that we all had our lockdown projects
and Putin's apart from studying history
was spending time in the map room in the
Kremlin looking at the ways in which
Russia's borders have changed over time
and thinking well if you know history
doesn't stay still you know Empires they
rise they fall or they move and so he
developed a slightly different I think
view about what what a strong manner
what a great leader can do to to to to
change those borders I mean they're kind
of interesting I guess one of the
interesting questions about all of this
is because we failed or because the
system failed or because the
circumstances were as they were in 2014
um effectively Russia took control over
the main regions that it really needed
access to so Crimea but also the parts
of of Don bass and yet
if Putin had done what a sane sensible
non-opportunist would have done was to
say I'm going to lock that in and we'll
take two or three generations and
eventually the process of time will be
such that you know it's unrecoverable
military force we get rid of the crazies
who will run around the military
fatigues we'll have some form of either
whether it's appointed Governors or
whether it's a his strong man or
whatever it was he could have formalized
it the question is what was the point in
trying to accelerate this and once it
was clear on day three that the battle
plan wasn't working
what was it he well it's next I mean
he's so he again in the same essay he
calls key of the mother of Russian
cities so it's quite hard to see how he
Scrolls back and retires to Sochi or
detaches and says well if that's some
other Russian cities how can it be
outside Russian hands which is very
similar to how she talks about Taiwan as
a matter of fact you have drawn us into
the next topic which is the end of this
you mentioned Fiona Hill Margaret she
said the worst piece is a recipe for
more war how do you
calculate on this ending
well that's always the problem with Wars
Those Who start them don't think enough
about the endings and we're not all
thinking enough about what comes next I
mean there's some attempt being made the
Germans are sponsoring a congress a
conference in Berlin to talk about what
happens when peace comes which I think
is really important we were talking
about this a bit in the green room and
then the the terrifying thing and the
unfortunately I think something that is
very likely is we'll end with a frozen
conflict and Putin has a number of
Frozen conflicts around his borders
where Ukraine is constantly worrying
about what's happening over in the East
constantly worrying about subversion
constantly worrying about hacking
attacks constantly worrying about
misinformation disinformation worrying
about internal subversion and has kept
off balance and is unable to do the the
I mean the huge job now of rebuilding
Ukraine which you know goodness I can't
even imagine how this is going to be
funded and how this is going to take
place and that I think is is the
dangerous thing that the conflict won't
be settled it will remain like this
opens sore draining Ukraine of resources
and and causing continual instability on
the slightly more cheerful side it may
be that Russia is going to be less
capable of causing International damage
I mean if Putin has done one thing uh
what part from creating a much stronger
Ukrainian nationalism I mean he should
be regarded as one of the fathers of
Ukrainian Independence I think but if
he's done one thing which he didn't
intend to do he has much reduced the
power and influence and authority of
Russia in the world and Russia more and
more looks like a dependent of China
which is I'm sure not what he intended
when it all started
Peter the end have you speculated have
you pondered at how this ends well
Margaret's so eloquent I mean the right
thing in as any student knows is to shut
up when you're in the presence of
greatness I'm not say anything so I've
got very little I can now that will make
me look anything apart from you know
clearly it's Putin not being in position
however that might happen I mean I think
there's no question that Putin can be
part of any form of settlement but it's
much much deeper than all of that I mean
if you've been watching it and they've
been you know social media is great to
be able to show to the outside world
what's being said on Russian TV every
night I mean it's it's pure poison about
the way in which you know commentators
regular Joseph never picked up a rifle
talk about the Houston nuclear weapons
and you know and attacks on outside on
other other parts of the world so it's
quite hard to see how one rose back from
this I mean as Margaret said when we
think this through I mean if if that
Ukrainian Advance continues as it looks
like it might do as you know and I
suppose we should hope that it does if a
full Ukrainian recovery of Don bass
maybe Crimea has a separate category I
mean you can discuss that you know who
who goes to live there it's quite hard
to see how ukrainians have come out will
want to be resettled to a frontier
region yeah and the big long-term
tactical advantages that Russia has is
that it can unfreeze whenever it wants
and the only way which we can have skin
in that game is lies in the Cold War to
invest very heavily in our military and
to and also to invest very sensibly in
our military just giving money isn't
very helpful I mean I did something with
with Mike Mullen who was the previous
chair of the Joint Chiefs of the US
Armed Forces a few years ago before the
pandemic and he said the single best of
the United States could do is to cut the
U.S defense budget because if you have
680 billion dollars a year to spend you
need to find a home for it and that
encourages you to use it and encourage
you to get involved in at that time Iraq
Syria and Afghanistan and so on so the
the long-term solution is it's really
hard to see you know I know there's lots
of chatter particularly in the states
about potential
dissolution of Russia Civic unrest
there's zero sign of that on the ground
so far as anybody could it helps that
you control the media helps you can
round up young men and throw them into
the army I mean this afternoon we've
seen um you know Russian telegram
channels newly drafted Russian forces
wearing inflatable body armor right that
looks like looks like body armor but
actually is like a like a Lifest that
you keeps a child afloat being sent to
the front line so presumably at some
point there comes some response from
those men and their families as there
was in Afghanistan that's what really
brought the Soviet Union down to to pull
out of our kind of standard 17 in the
1980s before we get to the the bad bits
and the ending is always difficult to
talk about
um I do think we can all hang on to one
really good thing and that is back in
February and March an awful lot of
people were terrified that Ukraine was
simply going to be wiped off the map by
Russia now the one thing we can say with
near certainty is that the only outcome
of this this war that is not going to
happen is is a Russian victim see that
Ukraine is going to continue to exist so
that is the good news and we should
always hang tightly to the good news
um what's much more difficult as we talk
there's a very good essay in the
American Magazine Foreign Affairs
um by an American Economist who said as
you touched on a moment ago Margaret the
difficult part is you said even if
um the Russian army can't beat the
ukrainians uh that Russia can make
Ukraine an unbelievably horrible place
to live and work in and when we're told
that it will cost about 500 billion to
put Ukraine back together again the
Russians aren't going to pay that now I
personally and I've been accused of
being a deficitious northern Pisa by
saying this I should be very surprised
if any outcome gets the Russians out of
the Crimea
but I also think and I think we all
ought to be thinking about this
we're going to have to find ways of
getting securing some guarantees for
Ukraine out of any ending of this war
that prevents the Russians from doing it
again and I do think we're going to have
to think very seriously about something
we didn't think about before whether
Ukraine should be admitted to Nato first
of all it seems right that the Russians
should have to pay a price for the
costly things they've done there
secondly unless one does offer some
security guarantees what's to stop the
Russians starting this up again anytime
they feel like and but none of these are
easier because for example France and
Germany well absolutely they will be
horrified at any notion of Ukraine
belonging to Nato but I think the things
we must think about how are we going to
find the money in Europe and the United
States to put Ukraine together again and
how are we going to stop the Russians
from doing this again the answers aren't
easy but we can at least try and pose
the right questions at this point
Margaret you mentioned Frozen conflicts
and there's a number around the world
some closer some further away from
Europe
do they ever unfreeze and if they do how
well they unfreeze if one side decides
to turn them into a hot War which is is
always a danger which is what happened
in Ukraine
they can be mediated at the moment talk
of an International Community seems a
bit optimistic you know the UN which has
so often played a part in trying to
mediate conflict and coming in for
reconstruction in post-conflict
situations I think is is much weaker
than it was and the fact that both China
and Russia have vetoes on the security
Council limits I think the effect of us
what it can do but yes we know that
conflict can be overcome we know that
peace can be made I mean if you had been
predicting in 1945 that Russia and
Germany would be working with each other
and would the Russian the German
Chancellor and the French President
would meet and Shake Hands On the Border
and and exchange you know greetings you
you we would have said impossible and so
things can change but how they change
without a good deal of outside
intervention I think is is tricky
because the trouble is that so often in
in conflicts those in power have have a
vested interest in maintaining them if
not turning them into open conflicts but
it's it's a way of maintaining status so
I'm not very optimistic about what's
going to happen in the case of
particularly the Ukraine if those
conflicts become Frozen again and Peter
can I ask you about other external
actors here I mean we we heard this
Rumblings of it was it at the Shanghai
cooperation Council where there was what
clearly an expression of concern from
India and China about what was going on
do you see any role there
well Max has given a shout out to his
book so be rude for me not to give a
shout out to mine if you if you uh I
promise you if you were ever interested
in thinking that maybe the Silk Roads
there's something in it
um in September we had in Central Asia
it's in Kazakhstan and then in samakand
uh the little China India Pakistan Iran
Russia the pope uh you know all South
Asian countries uh all Gathering
Afghanistan to representatives and I
think that that that's like a lot of
clubs exists for compromise reasons
these are lots of marriages and
convenience that are very messy and
difficult there's almost nothing that
any of these countries really have in
common apart from some some very light
glue that hold the The Narrative is
important and the narrative for many of
them that's very persuasive is the West
has had it too good for too long you
know yeah we colonized parts of the
world from Europe uh we are much richer
than other parts of Europe uh it doesn't
really matter whether the structural and
major problems economic social political
Narrative of grievance that's right and
also in fact as well I mean that's it's
also in fact I mean the reason we're
richer in this part of the world is
because we did do quite well out of
other continents whether we gave them
Railways cricket and God knows what else
you know we built the the industrialized
West managed to rise on the fact that it
able was able to get resources cheaply
from other parts of the world I think
that's just how it is having said that
many of the countries that I just
mentioned have been free and mastered
their own destiny for quite a long time
now so it's how do you how do you have a
script and historians that's what we're
also about is having a narrative art
that explains why we are as we are so
that meeting in samachand was hugely
important because it was pre the Optics
where this is a world without the West
this is where 65 of the world's
population live east of Istanbul we have
between us you know significant energy
needs and and and
resources and we should shape the world
in the way we want and that starts by
not taking orders from the West
when you get into one level below that
what does that actually mean it's more
complicated and what was very important
about this Shanghai team was two things
first some of the heads of smaller
states that Kyrgyzstan kept Putin
waiting
and that doesn't get done either by
chance nor does it get done without
consultation with one big power in your
corner behind you that you're sure of
and I'm not going to give you too many
guesses for which one that might be so
that architecture of what is happening
in Eurasia has been fundamentally
changed and of course the second thing
was that both um she and also Modi spoke
up and said this is not the time for war
um you know you shall go back home and
find a way of being peaceful without
giving too much of a road map but you
you can see that what Russia has done by
reducing its own Global standing by
executing a badly executive War if
nothing else and having no exits that's
obvious in terms of how do you
reintegrate and whatever however good or
bad a settlement might look like that
sets a bad example for these countries
that have traditionally not looked for
Russia for alliances and friendships and
strategic importance we read a lot into
that we think that the Russian and
Chinese axis is something real you know
this is a marriage of convenience that
that suits one side probably more than
it suits the other but what Russia has
done is it's shown this not competent
reading the global tea leaves and that
that is as dramatic as the economic
damage that's happened to Russia and so
on and and is coming towards us so that
that Central Asian meeting in Samarkand
of all these great Powers was a real
sort of Turning Point I think and what
we'll see now is what is it that Asia
means for the peoples of Asia this this
evening on the way here uh Biden said
he's not going to turn up the Asia
Pacific economic conference because he's
going to go to his granddaughter's
wedding instead and although that's a
sort of Highly superficial
um the Optics of that are the West is
detaching itself the United States of
other things to do than to be getting
involved in places like Indonesia
Philippines Thailand you know countries
are populations Pakistan population 230
million people and their Futures are
also highly dependent on Energy prices
they don't have a Jeremy Hunt who can
throw money or whoever it is in charge
uh while we're well this is being
broadcast they don't have those safety
nets and there's real anxiety I think
about what is coming towards us
particularly as proper sanctions kicking
on 6th of December so that that world
looks solid there is a there is a sort
of push towards Unity I mean the brics
countries China Brazil India all
abstained from the vote just to to
condemn Russia for its annexations of
Ukraine so that you know we should take
that all quite seriously my own view for
what it's worth is we need ministers in
the air going to visit these places all
the time rather than sitting here
working on which seat they're going to
be in tomorrow you know we don't we
don't invest enough in our International
relationships partly because it brexit
I'm afraid is part of that story partly
because we expect and we've learned over
the last 30 40 years if we sit here
people will turn up and do business with
us in London and you know if we want to
do we want to keep our security Council
see do we want to be a global power and
you know Max you're right there's an
American war run from the Pentagon but
the British armed forces have been
absolutely first rates uh through this
process too there are some things we do
in this country universities too that we
really do incredibly well and it's how
do we play a role in shaping some of
those conversations because I'll finish
with that you know lots of these times
that there are events in Samarkand or
Kazakhstan that I go to I'm almost
always the only European and I'm always
the only Brit in the room but almost
always the only European and it needs
people to be studying spending time
meeting listening wondering what it is
that people want and we haven't done
that particularly well in Iraq Syria
Afghanistan and that's given people like
lavrov quite a lot of collateral to play
with to say look what the West do we're
coming with a different solution could
we suggest that since the end of the
Cold War
um an awful lot of societies in the west
notably including Britain have allowed
us ourselves the luxury of what I would
call frivolity including choosing
unbelievably frivolous leaders I would
suggest I would suggest that we've now
entered a new era in which
um we've got to get serious again in
which I'm not just talking about the
local domestic issues one is thinking of
issues like the Ukraine war climate
change all the rest of it we have got to
ReDiscover the capacity to be a serious
country and to be led by serious
politicians instead of comics
okay
thank you
thank you very much indeed and that
brings just to an end of the bit where I
throw questions at This brilliant panel
and towards the bit where you throw
questions or put questions to them
um questions uh from the standing
microphones you can see them there and
there and I can see one perched up there
on the gallery I will try and come to
the gallery I promise that makes me
squint and also from our online audience
as well we have one question coming in
please feel free if you are at home and
watching this online use the space
beneath the screen to put your question
to me and it will or to our panel rather
not to me I have no answers
um and they will attempt to answer them
I'm going to go first to the standing
microphone here if you would sir thank
you very much
um Nelson Mandela famously said
that history is not made by Kings and
Generals
it's made by masses of ordinary men and
women
rather than paying tribute
to President Biden
should we not in fact be paying tribute
to the inspirational struggle by masses
of ordinary men and women in Ukraine who
are going to defeat
this murderous war and in so doing are
going to inspire working people in
Russia to themselves put paid to the
Putin secret police regime thank you
very much sir
um the general point there history made
by the masses history made by the
leaders and the elites Max
I think one I think the two are not
mutually exclusive I'm quite sure that
everybody in this Hall shares admiration
for the extraordinary fortitude and
courage of ukrainians but that does not
exclude we should not take anything for
granted and I certainly will not dare
take for granted Ukraine would not still
exist but with the support of the United
States the United States has had at
least one president in recent years who
would not have given such support and I
do not apologize for thinking that we
should be extraordinarily grateful to
the current president yeah I think also
well the point I mean it's an absolutely
fair fair punch we should also
absolutely be talking about the the
determination of Ukrainian people and
the leadership of apologies to uh to
defend their Homeland you know and I
think that we have that experience too
here in the Second World War II what it
means to go and fight for your country
it's a it's a hugely powerful thing to
to do and to see in the and the
determination courage of the Ukrainian
people to stand in line and fight rather
than accept Russian Overlord ship I
think it has been hugely inspiring and
it's it's I think a fair point that we
can take that for granted by thanking
people outside but I think we take as a
given that you stand and defend your
family names no and I think Max is is
right you could the two things are not
mutually exclusive I mean Churchill said
to the Americans during the second world
war one of the darkest times for Britain
give us the tools and we'll finish the
job you can't do the job unless you have
the tools and so if there had been a
different president in the white house
it is quite possible if Trump had been
in office those tools would not have
come to Ukraine and no matter how Brave
the Ukrainian soldiers are and they are
very brave and they have shown a
tremendous skill and and daring and
tactical and strategic
um Brilliance however good they were
without the tools
they couldn't have done it okay so hi
thank you very much um if we look at um
this current situation one man thinks
that the true um destiny of Russia is to
control the rich farmlands and the Water
Board of Ukraine others may think that
the real uh asset that Russia has to
protect is Siberia its oil riches and so
on and that is actually at risk we have
the historical priesthood of the
Khrushchev solution is there any way of
looking underneath the Bonnet and
understanding the forces at play here
amongst the Russian Elites and how that
may work because removing Putin sending
him to Sochi allows Russia to withdraw
and pivot to protecting its current very
valuable assets in the east
who wants to take that on first he
thought I would have thought well I
don't think there's any military
strategic threat to any Russian Assets
in Siberia or anywhere else so um I
don't think that's an issue I think the
the bigger problem for Putin now is to
exploit Arctic natural resources which
you can't do without Western capital and
technology in know-how so I don't think
that pivot away from Ukraine opens up
other areas where Russia has exposure I
don't recognize that at all no and what
Russia has lost is the people who could
exploit the oil and gas in the in the
East I mean they've lost so many of
their Highly Educated people
um it's you know it's been and you and
they're still losing them and this is
going to be a serious problem for Russia
in the long run they've lost some of
their most educated people and then you
can't replace them easily
okay so I want to go up up to the
gallery I am informed that there are
people there despite the Blazing lights
yeah is there someone at the microphone
um can you hear me okay good evening
um may I ask the
apparent um stalemate or something close
to it which will be the end of this war
maybe with this buffer zone
how would Putin possibly sell those at
home specifically now that more recruits
are going into the war possibly badly
equipped and more deaths are occurring
how can Putin sell those to his own
people as a victory
thank you very much indeed uh I mean can
a stalemate be sold
um at the end of a war like this
what does what does it do to his own
position
um within Russia I mean he has sold an
image of himself as the wise the
powerful leader who is Victorious if he
were now to say
um we've got a stalemate we've lost a
lot of lives we've lost the bulk of our
military equipment we're looking our
military is looking pretty foolish I
think his own position in in Russia
would become very difficult indeed I
think he's got no choice now but to go
for victory
well if you control the Press you can
sell anything as a victory you know I
mean that's the big advantage of the
organs of propaganda so I mean at the
beginning of the war the Russian Russian
uh public opinion insofar as it could be
measured in Pew research which is you
know as good as one can get in terms of
scraping the data uh there was huge
popularity for what what Putin was doing
it showed that Russia was able to stand
up on the global stage and in fact 85
percent of people who were surveyed and
it's not my research not my work not My
Views
um believe that Russia could go for
Poland next
that that has now all so far as we can
see dissipated but you know Point made
by uh other Russian commentators is that
we've seen no Ambassador rule defections
we've seen no one switch sides we've
seen no one in the Russian high command
look like that they have disobeyed
orders
um it looks like people are Fair Square
behind so how this gets sold if it's a
bad result is that Russia wasn't
fighting Ukraine it's fighting the West
which is what it looks like and the
Putin will say his the Russian time will
come and for now we will take stock
rebuild our military and go again and
that that I think is takes us back to
the Frozen war and how do we then find a
web it's not for us to find an off-ramp
for him it's not for us to find a
solution that he can sell or work out it
probably doesn't help that we have this
prominent private citizens in the United
States in particular proposing peace
settlements that that they think would
work for the Ukrainian people this has
got to come from a settlement that looks
right for this against the people of
Ukraine I had an experience um 20 years
ago when I was working quite a lot in
Russia and interviewing veterans of
World War II my very sophisticated very
liberal Russian researcher
um she told me in Moscow and this was
just after 9 11 and she said most of the
people that one meets in Moscow
um they're absolutely delighted about 9
11. they think the Americans had it
coming they think they've been so
arrogant for so long and they love to
see them on the ship and I was shocked
at the time to hear this said but it
gave me an insight into the depth of
this Russian Narrative of grievance and
victimhood and the degree of resentment
which I think I mean we find it almost
incomprehensible that Putin should have
any residual support at all in Russia
for and yet there's so many Russians who
this hatred and resentment of the West
and this desire to see us put down and
our arrogance punished and so on and I
think it's a very real ongoing Force but
Peter you're more up to date than I am
about I think that's right it's a source
of great mystery to me because you know
Russia is a beautiful country and the
people are fantastically creative
interesting Dynamic energetic but this
is what happens when you don't have
institutions that protect absolute power
and we I think we should be grateful for
the fact that in this country and other
places for all of the mudsling in our
politicians do those institutions do
function but we shouldn't take those for
granted too I think the problem with
with authoritarian autocratic rule is
that either you go mad at some point or
you get power hungry or there's no sort
of there's no Crown Prince to Putin if
there was a succession line then you
could open up discussions with who might
follow next and we've shown that quite
well of all the things we've done wrong
this country we did quite well when her
majesty died of seen that transition to
happen smoothly and that that is
something we should be thinking about
also in the case of of China and Jew
because I've mentioned China quite a few
times tonight about about understanding
how other people see us because like you
said max it comes as a real shock to see
how we perceived because that's not how
we see ourselves we see we're tolerant
we don't get everything right we try to
do things the right way we welcome
people to come and buy our football
clubs and apartments to push the price
how's the prize up that that works if
you haven't happened to buy a house at
the right time doesn't help young people
but I think that that idea of of what
now comes next uh asks very fundamental
questions about Russia I am acutely
aware that people are queuing at the
microphones and I have not forgotten you
however there are also people popping
questions in uh online and I want to go
to some of those or at least one of
those a remarkable number about the end
of the the war to come you can't cheat
Max by looking at the question
um and again this this this this this
suggestion that an off-ramp away should
be found uh to allow Russia and Vladimir
Putin to have peace with honor from
Camilla Redfern uh how can the war in
Ukraine be ended with both sides
believing that they are winners Margaret
shaking your head at the thought of it
no I think the war current banded by
anyone except the ukrainians and the
Russians and the idea that the rest of
us can somehow go in and say we are here
to dispense peace and friendship we
can't do it and actually I'm not sure we
have the moral right to do but I don't
think we have the influence to do it I
mean what is happening and this happens
in Wars it's on the ground what happens
on the ground is going to play a very
large part outside powers can can help
they can perhaps mediate but in most
wars when outside Powers often to
mediate they're told to buzz off
um you know I just don't see the week we
have to understand that it's up to the
ukrainians and the Russians and that's
why I think what's going to happen in
the next few months is going to be
extremely important okay I'm going to go
to the questioner here if you would sir
thank you um not my view but what do you
make of the Russia apologists in in
Western Europe or in the U.S who say
well Russia was justified in The
Invasion because well Hitler and
Napoleon both came through Ukraine we
attacked through Crimea in the past
so Russell was justified away from the
crap history essay that [ __ ] wrote he
was justified to protect himself what do
you make of those apologies what do you
make of the the apologists that the way
that our question of phrase is that the
apologists within the West who say that
there was a justification to this war
I'm afraid I think a lot of them um and
the mainland there are fewer in Britain
than there are in Europe but I'm sorry
to say that I think that an awful lot of
Europeans in the last 30 years have
given up on security and Putin is right
about some of them and some of those who
are saying well we must see the Russian
side of this are saying this because
they don't want the gas to be turned off
and it is going to be a huge challenge
this winter especially maintaining up
the unity of the West and of course all
the time this is Putin's calculation all
the way through he believes that we are
weak he believes that our Unity will
crack and as soon as the lights start
going off
um that the West is going to be
support for um for Ukraine is going to
be ebbing away and it's going to be
jolly difficult to keep it going but of
course we have to keep it going but I'm
afraid it's heartbreaking I mean that I
was in speaking in Holland at the
weekend and I did ask some of the highly
intelligent sophisticated Dutch people
who I was talking to about their view
about security has Holland has Germany
have they started to get serious about
security the answer is still just look
how many weapons Germany has delivered
to Ukraine so far almost none they
promised quite a few they've delivered
almost not how many weapons the Italians
the French the French Behavior dare I
say it my speakers are Francophile but
the French are fuselanimity about
Ukraine has been despicable is
Despicable so it's a very difficult
issue and it's going to be very tough
keeping maintaining European Unity on
this crisis and it's heartbreaking to
see because the one thing in the cold
war that it's amazing how well NATO
solidarity and European solidarity held
together and it is a challenge if Putin
him was allowed to emerge as a winner
from all this it would be a generational
catastrophe for for us all
okay well this also I think is in the
U.S you see it there are those who
admire power and admire Putin
um Tucker Carlson that ornament of your
profession
um says you know that Putin is a man
Putin is vigorous Putin knows what to do
and so I I'm afraid this probably as as
there was in in Britain and France
before the second world war there were
an admiration for those who are decisive
and seem to be strong there's this I've
mentioned gender before but there is a
sort of element I don't want to overplay
it but there's an element of an
admiration for what is seen as masculine
qualities and the amazing thing about it
all is that like Hitler Putin is
unbelievably indecisive right I mean
it's the terrible crisis of leadership
you can't work out what you should do so
you micromanage you interfere and you
choose both options every single time
and that's part of the Strategic problem
and weakness thank you let's go back
upstairs if we may and again I I'm
squinting into the light so who's next
to a microphone madam
um I just wanted to draw on something
that Mr
America and the Deliverance of weapons
and NATO and
um correct me if I'm wrong but um I
think one of the
um commitments of NATO when it was
founded was a two percent spending of
the GDP on defense and pretty much none
of the countries that are a part of NATO
except the USA spend that amount of
money on defense and I was wondering if
you thought that if
um the like European countries such as
the UK Germany started to spend that
sort of money on defense we would have a
better like stabilized ground to be able
to deal with such crisis as when they
arised
I'll I'll pick it just because some
actors want to do about about NATO and
GDP spending
um interestingly there are countries
that spend not just their their
specified about the more it's like
Croatia and the Baltic states uh Trump
for them all the madness and all the
disruption was absolutely right that
NATO countries in Europe are getting a
free ride and they're not investing in
their security particularly uh Germany
where for a considerable period of time
there were no not a single military
helicopter able to take in the air
um and Trump was right about North
stream providing dependency on Russian
gas as well so if you assume that the
world is all going to run in your favor
and you assume you don't need to spend
on defense or you assume that you don't
need the gas storage that we used to
have in this country that we shut down
because we thought we'd always be able
to rely on a stable world then the
problem is like with a pandemic if you
don't invest in your critical facilities
when something bad happens you have to
spend 40 times more so that should be as
a few lessons that perhaps are
Publishers will talk about as it happens
uh prime minister trust if she's still
in charge this evening has promised the
three percent expenditure which amongst
the many things she's promised I've yet
to see whether that's one of the things
that's also going to be scrapped the
only thing you wish I said that
seriously anything you've said tonight
Peter that I hadn't agreed with you okay
just tribute to our Armed Forces but we
have to keep reminding ourselves our
armed forces are ridiculously small and
they've been a large since the end of
the Cold War they've been run down to
extraordinary level we've depleted our
own inventories of weapons we can send
to Ukraine we're training ukrainians
yeah but we should be in no doubt that
the biggest danger of the size of our
Armed Forces uh you know somebody said
to me what what would the Chinese app do
if we sail our aircraft carriers to the
South China Sea I said the biggest
statement for the Chinese is they die
laughing because
um the idea we we have allowed this we
should not delude ourselves about our
own Armed Forces
um we've had a terrific wake-up call a
terrifying wake-up call and we've got to
spend a lot more money and that is not
going to be popular no none of our
leaders yes Liz truss has said we've got
to raise
um defense spending three percent
nobody's really talked through the
implications about what we're gonna but
if we're serious about security we've
got to spend the money agreed
um I will come back to the audience here
I want to pick up on a question I think
particularly to Margaret if I may
um that's come in online
um how do you think the war will shape
future Societies or relations between
nations do you think there's a potential
for a return to an iron curtain type
situation or state in years to come is
it too early to start calling that one
Margaret Wars do leave depending on the
nature of the war and they do leave
often very
great scars and and great consequences I
think for countries not directly
involved in the war we will move on and
perhaps tend to forget it although we
will have I think in the west and the
West I should say is is not really a
geographical term it's it's a term of
encompassing like cultural I mean
Japan's part of the western Australia's
part of the West so you know but I think
countries which adhere to democratic
values constitutional government rule of
law will after this war regard Russia
with a lot more suspicion I think and I
think what the war has done if it's done
anything good is forced peoples in the
west to Define what it is they think is
important and what values they think are
important what it will do to the
relations between ukrainians and
Russians it's hard to see that these
will become anything but bitter in the
next day you know it'll take at least a
generation and the more that comes out
about how Russian troops have been
behaving in Ukraine I think the more
difficult it's going to be for
ukrainians to forgive and the Russians
if they end up up with with a defeat are
going to be humiliated and humiliation
is not also a good basis for making
friends with your neighbors we're doomed
to be in an adversarial relation with
them yeah I mean you know he says the
right Russians Ukrainian are brothers
and we've all had pretty tasty
Christmases where things kick off but
it's it's it's quite hard to see how you
come back from that if this is the way
you treat the people who you regard and
you write detail histories to say we're
born from the same mother we're all the
same people it's a it's a pretty bad
position to be in if you're Russian to
try to think how do we undo this as
Margaret said the behavior of the troops
on the grand Max has said on the
behavioral troops on the ground it's
been absolutely abysmal losing
dishwashers and so on and that's been
seen around the world you know that's
not not a particularly positive sign for
the long term Margaret for 30 years we
thought that trade would change
countries whose systems of government we
didn't believe win or or that we were
opposed to previously that doesn't
appear to have been the case there's
always been this illusion that the more
you trade together the more you're going
to like each each other it doesn't work
out that way the whole time quite often
you you get jealous you you don't like
the fact your markets are being cut into
look Britain and Germany were each
other's greatest trading partners before
the first world war and they should have
been friends and Norman Angel wrote a
very persuasive book I mean people
studied it and people set up groups like
this to study angelism a Norman Angel
argued that because the European
economy's economies were so tightly
intertwined there could be no war it
wouldn't make sense war is not something
that is always rational and all you know
it's the same argument that a lot of
people have made with China the closer
that we get to China economically of
course the more intertwined the American
and Chinese economies are the more
likely they'll be friends we'll look at
them today
sir you've been waiting very patiently
thank you very much thank you thank you
so a few weeks ago a far-right Dutch
politician stood up in Parliament and
said he thanked Putin for opening a new
front against globalism the world
economic Forum George Soros and the
American deep State and this is palpably
ridiculous obviously but it makes me
wonder is there something exportable
about the Russian ideology the way
Marxism leninism was during the Cold War
is it being exported and if it is being
exported what do we do against it thank
you very much Margaret can I come to you
it's being it's being exported to
countries around Russia Serbia for
example which has always had strong
links with Russia not all serbs and I
don't want to suggest that all subs
think this but this certainly is a
strand in Serbian politics which is and
you see it in Hungarian Politics as well
um you know that there are some of the
ideas of and and you referred I mean
there are these conspiracy theories that
George Soros somehow in the world
economic Forum among them around the
world and this appeals I think to people
who feel powerless I can you know
conspiracy theories tend to do that but
I don't I think I see Russia actually as
as an importer of ideas as well I mean
it's important fascist ideas it's
imported ideas of the nation um the
Eternal Nation I mean I think it's a
two-way street
I think one thing one historical lesson
that is worth mentioning
um Churchill in 1940 at a time when
Britain was entirely beleaguered and uh
one evening at Checkers
um a whole group of ministers and uh his
staff were all talking about Germany and
agreeing that all sorts of terrible
things have got to be done to Germany uh
after its defeat
um which at that time seemed very remote
and Britain was completely embattled and
Britain was losing
um and Churchill intervened after he
listened to some of this and he said no
no all this talk about pastoralizing
Germany and so on so forth he said
Germany was part of the European
community of Nations up before Hitler
came and it must be again and I thought
it was an example of Churchill as his
absolute best that in those desperate
days in I forget June or July 1940 he
could display the the compassion and the
generosity to envisage a future in which
Germany will come back and in the same
way I guess we have to be optimistic
enough to hope that one day Russia may
come back bloody difficult at the moment
but nonetheless I do remember that
example of Churchills which part of his
generosity of spirit and it's very hard
to display generosity of spirit in the
middle of a war as ghastly as this one
Peter can I put something to you that's
coming online and and whilst I'm sure
the panel disagrees and many in the
audience May completely it's a common
theme of questioning and of Point making
um what do you answer what do you say to
people who believe the West provoked
Russia by wanting Ukraine to join the EU
and NATO
foreign
the EU didn't
Court Ukraine it's what Ukraine wants
it's up to you to decide whether they
want to admit them
so I'm sort of slightly you know it's I
I'm very happy to bash the West for all
sorts of sins
but I think we have to be slightly
constructive about allowing
self-determination when people want to
join NATO or you then the institutions
have the right to work out whether they
should be admitted and what the risks
are and clearly Ukraine is a sensitive
issue I think that all military
strategists and you know sensible
politicians have understood that it's a
sensitive issue through the dark days of
Revolutions in in Ukraine in the last
decade in particular in terms of what
that meant for strategic importance and
the signaling from the West has been
pretty clear that we understand that
it's an issue that parking missiles and
and so on in Ukraine is not going to be
acceptable for for Russia and there was
no proposal look that would happen but
it does seem valid doesn't it that after
the Cold War the West Was in very
triumphalous mode and especially the
Americans and there's not much doubt
that the Americans especially did rub
the Russians noses in their defeat in
the immediate aftermath in a way that
created the mindset so I totally agree
that um one thing the Russians will
never admit is that a Sovereign Nation
including Ukraine should have the right
to decide whether it belongs to you but
there's no doubt we did not behave with
much grace or dignity towards the
Russians in the aftermath of which what
we saw as their defeat Market sorry well
as my mother used to say two wrongs
don't make a right and you know we did
make mistakes of course we did but you
know this idea that Russia was given a
promise that not one inch Nita would not
expend one inch eastwards is not true
Mary Sarat has written a very good book
on it if anyone wants to read it called
not one inch actually
um but you know it was the countries of
the former Soviet Empire in Eastern
Europe who wanted to get into NATO
wanted to get into European Union
because they had lived under the
alternative
yeah you know to go back to what Max
said about the second world war you know
I suppose if there was a single
serious of the many mistakes that we
made and there were lots you know uh was
that we did a pretty good job in
incorporating countries in Eastern
Europe they've been hobbled by Warsaw
Pact and Soviet Rule and that was a
great virtue of the European Union and
what it did to bring up standards the
living not just in uh Eastern European
countries central European countries but
also in southern Europe it made us much
more inclusive and wealthier altogether
and we did by and large we'll get on
with each other we still do even though
we're out of out of that particular Club
here in the UK but the one thing perhaps
the biggest regret as a Russia
specialist was that when the Soviet
Union dissolved in 91 we missed the
chance to put some kind of Marshall Plan
for Russia you know we had we were good
at bringing in Poland Hungary
imperfectly and so on with all the flaws
but you know in fact we we almost did
the opposite not only did we help
support we helped the process of looting
systematically by allowing our law firms
here and our structures here you know
Britain is a world-class tax Haven
specialist in terms of K Cayman Islands
British Virgin Islands and so on
dependence crown dependencies and so on
and we thought it was sort of amusing
that people turned up with their Yachts
football clubs boats Etc and the whole
lot behind and and they arguably maybe
it was good trickle down to politics or
the money doesn't really work that way
and they're against us they're against
us and I think that because in the west
it's not hard to see I mean in Russia
it's not hard to see how we in the west
are portrayed as being complicit in the
Looting of Russian to Russians actually
but but there was no end of of oil
Executives waiting to fly into Moscow
you know if you visited Russia before
this you know it was a Boom Town filled
with chances and and investors trying to
sort of work out how to take advantage
of the of the fact that it was quite
easy to do business if you knew the
right people who knew the right way to
do things and we didn't encourage any of
the institutional development that we
not only could have done but some of us
think morally we should have done okay
I'm gonna ask the gentleman who's been
waiting very patiently there thank you
sir thank you when this terrible
Invasion first took place I remember
saying that this could conceivably turn
out to be the Putin's couches moment and
I'm really picking up on something Peter
said a few minutes ago and when he he
indicated that there were no signs of
any real opposition within Russia I
wonder whether that's the case behind
closed doors and there is a pattern in
history of um dictatorial Powers simply
collapsing almost overnight especially
when they face disaster especially
military disaster weren't all
credibility goes and all belief in them
goes and I think what we're seeing now
with the humiliation of the Russian army
at the hands of extraordinary Ukrainian
resistance
the entire Russian military machine I'm
going to put your point I'm going to put
your point if I measure to the panel if
I may think one of the members of the
panel thank you very much indeed
Margaret well you're right I think
dictatorships can be fragile and and
it's it's a bit like the emperor is no
clothes isn't it at certain point people
say wait a minute this isn't working for
us
um it's what's happening around today I
think you're getting what started out as
a protest over a young woman who was
killed by the by the religious police
who has sparked her death has sparked a
whole series of protests about lots of
things in Iran and the regime it may
survive but it certainly is looking very
much on its back foot and what may
happen I mean I I heard Catherine Belton
who wrote that extraordinary book
Putin's people talk the other day and
she said cracks are appearing in the
Russian Elites how deep they go is
difficult to tell because it's really
hard to know what's going on in Russia
at the moment but there are more people
speaking openly against Putin than we've
seen for a very long time and it may be
that you know we don't know what's
happening behind the scenes I mean the
best possible
thing perhaps that could happen is that
his regime collapsed but the thing we
think we then have to worry about is who
takes over and it may be someone even
worse it's unlikely to be a liberal
Democrat yeah exactly
maybe you've got a few spare British
politicians here you could ship some
over
um can I ask the lady here it's probably
gonna be our final question we
are the lack of plausibility for a third
world war but what do you think about
the notion that we're perhaps in another
cold war period what do you think about
the notion that we're in another cold
war period is that is that a fact I
don't think it's very important to say
this is not a rerun of the old Cold War
partly because this is not a bad
ideology there's no ideology at stake
here this is all about power and
territory
um on the other hand I do think and
going back to Margaret's Point earlier I
fear that despite we did try not as hard
as we should have done perhaps but we
did try to cohab cohabit reasonably
peacefully with Russia and China and to
get along with them but I'm afraid it
looks as if for the time being at least
the effort has failed and we are in an
adversarial relationship so I do think
we're in a what we're not in this I
think it's wrong to call it a second
Cold War because it's not the same thing
um but I do think we're in an
adversarial relationship with Russia and
China which allows is going to have to
persist and I come back and I'm not I
hope saber raffling here I think we've
got what to show a recognition of the
vital importance again to go back to the
Cuban Missile Crisis that President
Kennedy was able to Prevail in the Cuban
Missile Crisis because nobody in the
Kremlin indicted that he had both the
military means and the political will to
go to war if he had to and in the same
way today Putin has acted as he has
Because he believes that we are weak I'm
afraid I believe we're going to have to
spend a great deal of money on rearming
and if we fail to rearm if we fail to
address energy security also then I
think the prospects for for the West we
will have to face continuing aggression
new aggression acts of aggression and
I'm afraid all the old cliches are true
that the price of of security is
Vigilance and is a degree of
preparedness we had it in the Cold War
we don't have it now we've got to get it
back Margaret are we looking at a second
Cold War
no because I think among other things
about the Cold War was that it was a war
of ideologies it was a war of competing
visions of society and we don't have
that at the moment
um this is a war this is a war that is
much more familiar from the 18th 17th
16th century it's a war of aggression to
seize land
Peter Well my mother also told me that
two wrongs don't make it right but she
also said if you haven't got anything
clever to say then shut up
[Applause]
I'm going to draw things to a close we
are out of time our panel have been
extraordinarily generous with their time
their expertise and their experiences
the very good news is you will be able
to sample a little bit more of that
outside in the foyer where they will for
varying lengths of times be signing
books should you wish to purchase them
but I would like to say what a complete
Joy it has been to share the stage with
you to share this space with all of you
and those of you at home and thank you
to you all thank you
thank you Peter